[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back
with a snap of a finger
humanity once believed we were gods
with what this planet now faces they
will believe again
eternal's assembled
what's the plan
we fight
marvel studios eternal spray pg-13 only
appears november 5th you are about to
meet the greatest warriors the world has
ever known
legendary
fashionable
powerful
well i'm sure that was a lot of fun for
you it was
on november 5th the marvel universe play
nice becomes eternal so what's your
superpower
you know that your babysitting
privileges are completely revoked right
marvel studios eat turn off sweetie
pg-13 only peter's november 5th
we're eternals
we came here to protect humans from the
deviants
when you love something
you fight for it
dad i saw him on tv with the cape
shooting laser beams
i don't wear a cape
you can't protect
any of them
let's finish this
marvel studios eternal sweetie pg-13
only in theaters november 5th
you